Welcome back everyone this is the way this will
be my full mandalorian season 3 trailer video they
also release an ahsoka series teaser trailer
and i'll talk about the footage during this
too but they've only been filming that series
for about three weeks so there wasn't a lot of
footage but it was all the stuff from rebels that
you expected them to do during the ahsoka series
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
of course i'll be doing videos for all these
star wars episodes when the series premiere
because they didn't release the footage online i
have to work from a potato quality version of the
footage but they actually showed off two different
versions of the mandalorian season 3 trailer the
second version had a bunch of extra footage that
i'll talk about during this the big thing that
they were trying to hype up during the mandalorian
season 3 trailer was mando taking grogu and going
to the actual planet mandalore to try and fulfill
the requirements that the armor gave to him
during the book of boba fett episodes about how he
could redeem himself and become a true mandalorian
again but then they're trying to juxtapose
that against the wishes of bo katan kryze
along with the other mandalorians like the regular
mandalorians that aren't part of his special cult
and how they're trying to retake the throne of
mandalore from grand admiral thrawn in this giant
bigger plot with grand admiral thrawn the remnants
of the empire in moff gideon's former forces
giancarlo esposito was also at the panel with
them and he was making all kinds of jokes about
wanting to kill grogu now but remember they
captured him at the end of mandalorian season
2 so he's still in custody of the new republic
so all the footage that you see of him walking
around this planet surface with all the slag all
these rocks jutting out this is the actual surface
of the planet mandalore they made this big thing
during the end of the mandalorian season 2 along
with the book of boba fett episodes where they
talked about what had happened during the great
purge and how the planet was almost non-existent
like the forces of the emperor at the time because
this was happening during the early original
trilogy era basically bombarded it so badly that
the domes the mandalorians lived under along with
their underground cave system where he's supposed
to be going now to bathe in this special river or
supposed to have been completely destroyed but i
don't think that's meant to be completely true
i think that he will go to mandalore and they
will find a way because as they say this is the
way during the trailer you hear the armor who's
now in a new facility in a new planet talking to
him about what she said basically during the book
of boba fett you took your helmet off by choice
they make a couple jokes about grogu trying to
figure all this out the context for everything
because even though he's really close with mando
and he is very intelligent he's over 50 years
old he still doesn't totally understand all the
dynamics of what's going on between all these
different mandalorians like he's just trying to
keep up with all this like why do these other
mandalorians hate you so much what's going on
with the darksaber why is this so important the
armor reminds him that he is no longer mandalorian
at least by their creed they intercut footage
amanda walking around in this cave system going
to a different planet that's just more footage of
him looking around the former mandalore planet she
keeps saying that him finding redemption is
no longer possible because of what happened
with the great perch destroying everything on the
planet but i think that's meant to be misleading
they show you his new naboo starfighter hot
rod ship flying through hyperspace he's still
gonna be using that during the mandalorian
season three i think we all assumed that
then they have all this brand new footage with bo
katan kyrze who's a much bigger character during
season three much more episodes more footage the
hall that he's walking down looks very similar to
the main hall in the palace of mandalore with the
best guard throne the throne that she's sitting on
is meant to be a replica of the best guard throne
that's the reason this throne looks a little bit
different from the original mandalorian throne
you can actually see behind it there's this big
land mass so this isn't actually on the planet
mandalore where this is happening this is meant
to be on the new planet that she's been using as
their home base where they've been marshaling all
their forces remember she's had this long-running
plot these last several years where she's been
trying to steal from the empire gain more ships
so that they can completely retake the planet from
grand admiral thrawn and all his forces because
he's the true big bad moff gideon obviously very
bad but he's really kind of like a puppet next to
grand admiral thrawn who's the person who's meant
to really be pulling the strings here remember all
this part of the timeline the ahsoka series the
book of boba fett the mandalorian episodes are all
meant to eventually cross over in their version of
a big avengers end game avengers infinity war
level event in their version of thanos will be
grand admiral thrawn so that's why probably at
the end of the mandalorian season three there'll
be a teaser for actual grand admiral thrawn
in live action and then we'll see him for real
during the ahsoka series if it wasn't clear even
though ahsoka will probably have a cameo scene
during this all the events of the ahsoka series
those episodes will take place after the events
of the mandalorian season 3. and they did confirm
that the mandalorians season 3 will premiere in
february after the willow episodes get done that's
why it's not releasing in december they're just
waiting till after they finish all the willow
episodes there'll be eight episodes just like
there were in previous seasons it'll be the exact
same for the ahsoka series as well bogatan yells
at mando about how his sect of the mandalorians
the group of death watch that broke off
they stopped caring about the rest of mandalore
a long time before the actual purge happened
making it sound like they broke off a long time
ago remember when he met her for the first time
during season 2 she thought it was weird that he
would not take his helmet off like no dude we're
real mandalorians we do this all the time you're
just part of this crazy group of mandalorians that
are extra hardcore they show you more scenes
of mando walking through this underground cave
system this is probably him looking through the
original mandalore planet then he goes back to
navarro and things look like they're way better
off greif carga seems like he's taken over this
complete area like he's now in charge of the
entire planet they have a funny scene of a
bunch of salacious crumb animals sitting inside
a tree remember the last time we saw them they
had a joke about them being roasted on a spit
by a street vendor during season one things are
looking up for salacious crumbs race there's a
c-3po droid behind him greef karga has robes on
him that just make him look like he's taken over
charged as an administrator of the entire town
this is cena but looks like tim matheson is
a new character is part of the new republic
who seems like he's working with captain carson
tiva's character this probably has something to do
with the moff gideon plot because the new republic
forces the ones that are holding him in prison
there's a new roadian character helping him out
that's also part of the new republic forces peli
motto comes back she's inspecting mando's ship it
looks like this is also happening back on tatooine
so they go back to tatooine at some point because
boba fett also probably comes back after the
events of the book of boba fett they had the whole
plot with him taking over jabba's empire that
whole series so i think we all assumed that they
did that because it was going to be important for
what was happening during the mandalorian season
three like they were going to use boba fett's new
power his new forces that he'd marshaled then they
have all this brand new footage on the empire side
of things with dr purging and his cloning plot
of the force sensitive characters and grogu's
character remember there was the whole grogu
cloning plot that we were talking about back
towards mando season one then during season
two we saw the remnants of one of his failed
experiments trying to clone a bunch of human force
sensitives so we'll finally get some answers about
that there's a lot of vibes with this whole
overarching grand admiral thrawn grogu cloning
story from the heir to the empire trilogy grand
admiral thrawn during that storyline engineered
this luke skywalker force sensitive clone and
a clone of a jedi master called joris kaboth
trying to use them against the new republic so it
sounds like they've replaced that luke skywalker
clone plot with the grogu clone plot and grand
admiral thrawn is probably just trying to use him
grogu to create force sensitive clones to make
them way stronger like the way the moff gideon
developed the even stronger dark troopers from the
video games to make them super hardcore upgrades
from regular stormtroopers this looks like greef
carga just having a standoff in the middle of the
street then like i said mando declares to bogatan
with grogu watching him that he's going to go to
mandalore and try to redeem himself in the eyes
of his mandalorian sect that's why i say this
facility that she's in with the mandalorian throne
isn't meant to be on actual mandalore it's just
meant to be a similar replica to the throne room
on mandalore that you saw during the end of clone
wars it does look like very similar architecture
but the hallway is way smaller the throne room on
mandalore was way way bigger this is dr pershing
walking through an uber public facility probably
trying to stay under the radar there's footage of
a couple giant space battles with mando in his hot
rodded naboo one starfighter fighting a bunch of
other imperials a bunch of other forces you see a
couple giant capital ships one of the things that
wasn't in this version of the trailer that was in
the longer footage at star wars celebration was a
legit full star destroyer because we didn't see an
actual star destroyers during mandalorian season
2. moff gideon was just using a cruiser which is
quite a bit smaller i think the idea with them
showing giant star destroyers is the idea that
they're showing you grand admiral thrawn
or some teaser for him during season three
then they end the teaser with this funny
footage of bo katan talking to grogu saying
did you think that your father was the only
mandalorian so they're just trying to tell
you that you're gonna see way more mandalorians
and way more mandalore stuff during season three
it's all about their greater quest to retake
the planet mandalore from the forces of grand
admiral thrawn but the other thing they showed
off during the brand new footage was a bunch of
footage of baboo fricks race other members of
his race during this part of the timeline and
then they showed a bunch of separate new footage
from the ahsoka series they've only been filming
for the last couple of weeks but it was all stuff
that you thought that they were going to be doing
from star wars rebels so all of your theories were
probably correct they showed most of the crew of
the ghost from star wars rebels that shipped from
star wars rebels they had live action sabine wren
being played by this actress she was looking
at a version of the mural that you saw during
the end of star wars rebels but this was meant
to be in live action so that's confirming that
ezra bridger will show up in live action they will
show grand admiral thrawn there was a live version
of haracindala on their live-action version of
the ghost sitting next to ahsoka but they only
showed hera from behind i think that is actually
going to be mary elizabeth winstead's character in
real life she's actually ew and mcgregor's brand
new partner they just had a baby together she was
also at star wars celebration promoting stuff
with him while he was there promoting obi-wan
kenobi stuff with hayden christensen so i think
when they dropped the first actual ahsoka trailer
online you'll see her in live action as harra
sindala the whole thing with the ahsoka series
is that it's the search for grand admiral thrawn
in finding out what happened to ezra bridger when
they jumped into the unknown regions but then
eventually at some point came back because grand
admiral thrawn has come back since then so that
means that ezra bridger has also come back too
but they didn't reveal who's playing live-action
ezra bridger yet so that's still open to theories
if they drop a version of that mandalorian season
3 trailer online i'll do a brand new video for it
talking about a bunch of other stuff so if you
have any big questions about what's going on
during the series or the characters just write
them below in the comments darth vader just
came back on obi-wan kenobi my obi-wan kenobi
episode 3 video will post next wednesday after
they release it everyone click here for my full
obi-wan kenobi episode 2 video and click here for
my full episode 1 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!